HERE EXCLUSIVELY AS MASTERPIECE
CAKE SHOP OWNER JACK PHILLIPS
AND HIS ATTORNEY JEREMY TEDESCO.
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY BEING
TARGETED, WHO IS BEHIND THIS
LATEST ATTACK?
>> THIS TIME I FEEL LIKE I'M
BEING HARASSED, I'VE BEEN SUED
BY THE STATE TWICE NOW AND
THEY'VE LOST BOTH TIMES.
THE ATTORNEY THAT INSTIGATED THE
SECOND LAWSUIT AGAINST ME IS NOW
TAKING IT TO SUE ME PERSONALLY
AND THIS TIME ASKING FOR DAMAGES
AND LEGAL FEES WHICH WOULD LEAD
TO BANKRUPTCY AND RUIN MY
COMPANY.
>> Laura: JEREMY, HAS THIS
PERSON HARASSED JACK OVER EMAIL
AS WELL AND IS NOW WANTING TO
CAKE TO CELEBRATE GENDER
TRANSITION, WHAT DOES THAT CAKE
LOOK LIKE?
>> IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE TO SEE
THE KIND OF EMAILS THAT WERE
SENT TO JACK BUT WE CAN'T FORGET
THE STATE'S ROLE IN THIS.
IT'S OPEN HOSTILITY TO JACK HAS
CLEARLY CREATED A LACK OF
TOLERANCE FOR PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
STEPPING INTO THE SHOES OF THE
STATE AND TRYING TO DO TO JACK
WITH THE STATE COULDN'T DO.
>> Laura: AND THE
SUPREME COURT SAID YOU CAN'T
TARGET PEOPLE AND OFFEND THEIR
RELIGIOUS SENSIBILITIES IN THE
WAY THEY WERE TRYING TO DO WITH
THE FIRST GO AROUND WHEN IT CAME
TO THE CAKE FOR THE SAME-SEX
WEDDING.
>> THIS OPEN HOSTILITY TO
RELIGION HAS NO PLACE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND COLORADO CITIZENS
DIDN'T GET THE MESSAGE.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR JARED
PAULUS, THE LEFTIST GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE OF COLORADO,
ULTIMATELY HAD TO PULL BACK THIS
LAWSUIT BY SAYING THE PRIVATE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED, THAT PERSON
CAN SUE YOU AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
ARE YOU AN OBJECT LESSON FOR THE
WHOLE COUNTRY IF YOU DARE TO
STAND UP FOR YOUR OWN RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS, YOU WILL BE TIRED,
DEMEANED, AND YOURSELF
DEHUMANIZED AND THEY REALLY HURT
YOU FINANCIALLY, REALLY HURT
YOU.
>> THEY HAVE COME OF THE STATE
TOOK AWAY 40% OF MY BUSINESS
WHICH IS MY WEDDING BUSINESS THE
FIRST GO AROUND.
THE THING IS, I SERVE EVERYBODY
WHO COMES IN MY SHOP, I WELCOME
EVERYBODY, I WOULD BE GLAD TO
CREATE CAKES FOR ANYONE WHO
COMES IN BUT I DON'T CREATE
EVERY CAKE IN EVERY MESSAGE
PEOPLE ASK ME TO.
>> Laura: JEREMY, THIS IS A
MISSION, THIS IS A MISSION TO
SEND A MESSAGE, DON'T YOU DARE
DEMAND EQUAL ACCESS TO EXPRESS
YOUR VIEWS BECAUSE OUR VIEWS AND
OUR BELIEFS TRUMP YOURS, YOU ARE
A BIGOT.
ANY CHRISTIAN CONSERVATIVE WHO
THINKS LIKE JACK THINKS IS A
BIGOT, THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT TO
SAY.
>> THE GOAL IS TO SILENCE JACK,
TO BANISH THEM FROM PUBLIC LIFE,
TO FINANCIALLY RUIN HIM AND SEND
A MESSAGE OF INTIMIDATION TO
PEOPLE WHO SHARE HIS BELIEFS
THAT THEY HAVE NO PLACE IN
PUBLIC LIFE, THEY HAVE NO RIGHT
TO EARN A LIVELIHOOD AND FOLLOW
RELIGIOUS CONVICTION
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
>> Laura: THE ATTORNEY FOR THE
PLAINTIFF IS SAYING THIS IS
ABOUT HONORING THE DIGNITY OF
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING.
THAT HAS TO BE HONORED ACROSS
THE BOARD REGARDLESS OF YOUR
PARTICULAR CONSCIENCE OR
RELIGIOUS BELIEF, ARE YOU
DISHONORING PEOPLE'S DIGNITY?
>> IN THIS CASE THE CAKE THAT WE
WERE ASKED TO RATE WAS BLUE ON
THE OUTSIDE AND PINK ON THE
INSIDE AND COLORS WERE SPECIFIC
TO CELEBRATE THAT TRANSITION.
I WOULD BE GLAD TO SERVE
TRANSGENDER'S OR GAYS OR ANYBOD
ANYBODY, I CAN'T CREATE EVERY
CAKE AMASSED TO MAKE.
WE WILL SERVE YOU IN ANY OTHER
CAPACITY BUT THIS IS A CAKE, WE
WILL SERVE YOU, WE SERVE
EVERYBODY.